est mis sur pause depuis la mi mars 2020
la fête reprend ses droits dans les
boîtes de nuit française depuis ce
vendredi soir mais pour pouvoir investir
la piste de danse
il faut se plier aux contraintes du pass
sanitaire test qu'ovide de moins de 48
heures parcours vaccinale complété
depuis au moins deux semaines ou
attestation de guérison constitue le
sésame indispensable pour passer les
portes des établissements nocturnes des
obstacles qui font craindre aux
professionnels du secteur une reprise en
demi teinte content de réouvrir parce
que vous avez tellement longtemps donc
effectivement content de réouvrir mais
la foi j'appréhende un petit peu parce
que je ne sais pas comment des gens les
gens vont réagir comment ça va se passer
est ce qui va avoir les mêmes influences
qu'avant je ne pense pas mais c'est
vraiment aucun test en fonction sur
lequel en prenant les dispositions où
j'ai l'impression que les gens ont été
ont été emballés par la réouverture
notamment de lempire club
ils ont ils ont ils ont répondu présent
après ce qu'ils vont faire l'effort
encore une fois de faire un test pcr
ont-ils génique pour aller en
discothèque ça c'est vraiment une autre
problématique à l' empire discothèque de
banlieue parisienne
un dispositif de test antigénique est
installé par les gérants pour permettre
aux clients de présenter une preuve
valide à l'entrée on a eu des patients
qui se plaignait un peu mais après
franchement fin de mon point de vue je
trouve ça un peu abusé c'est vrai que ça
reste quand même très rapide on a une
prise en charge qui dure 10 minutes donc
franchement pour havret pouvoir aller
s'amuser en boîte de nuit sachant qu'on
sort d'une période de co vide donc en
soit franchement je trouve ça largement
satisfaisant qui vacciner j'ai mon qr
codes avec moi
je pense que c'est bien parce que il
faut se protéger donc je pense que c'est
bien de filtrer les entrées que je vais
essayer de garder la distance pour
éviter d'avoir le masque parce que vous
avec la chaleur c'est un peu compliqué
le mas
ouais c'est le garder la distance moi je
suis très contente de refaire la tête
ça faisait longtemps et ça m'avait a pu
manquer un retour sur la scène pour les
artistes également malgré une certaine
appréhension la chanteuse martiniquaise
maureen ne cachait pas son enthousiasme
à l'idée de se produire à nouveau en
boîte de nuit
clairement quand j'ai vu les conditions
je me suis si pur et c'est chaud est-ce
que tu montes viendra mais bon les gens
sont assez déterminée j'ai envie de dire
près d'un an et demi
resté confiné avec certaine mobilité
donc ouais c'est assez compliqué c'est
vrai mais pour la sécurité de tous c'est
préférable
malheureusement et voilà mais entre la
complexité liée aux contraintes
sanitaires et les difficultés
financières bon nombre de boîtes de nuit
ont décidé de rester portes closes en ce
9 juillet de réouverture